Selamlar, sevgiler. 9. sınıf tayfam.
Kanalıma hoş geldiniz. Ben Deniz Hoca.
Çalışmalarımıza kaldığımız yerden devam
ediyoruz. 9. sınıf ders kitabımız hemen
şu ekranda gördüğünüz üzere incelemek
isterseniz videonun açıklamalar kısmında
linki yer alıyor. İşte o kitaptan adım
adım ilerlemeye devam ediyoruz. Şimdiki
konumuz, bu videonun konusu güzel
sanatlarla edebiyatın ilişkisi yani
güzel sanatları ve bunun içerisinde
edebiyatın yerine göz atacağız. Yine
önemli sınavda da gerçekten buradan soru
gelecektir diye düşünüyorum. O yüzden
çok dikkatlice dinliyorsun. Öyleyse bu
videoyu beğendiysen, kanalıma abone
olduysan ekran değilsin ve hemen hiç
vakit kaybetmeden dersimize başlayalım.
Şimdi edebiyat nedir? Bir tanım yapmak
istersek şöyle bir tanım doğru olur mu?
Edebiyat insanın duygu, düşünce
hayallerini sözün büyüsüyle ya da
yazının kalıcılığıyla estetik bir zevk
uyandıracak biçimde ifade etme
sanatıdır. Yani duygularımız,
düşüncelerimiz, hayallerimiz var. Bu
duygu, düşünce hayallerimizin estetik
bir şekilde söz ya da yazıyla
aktarılması sanatına edebiyat denir.
Yani edebiyat aslında bir sanat mıdır?
Evet, edebiyat bir sanattır diyebiliriz.
İşte şimdi diğer güzel sanatlara bakacak
olursak yani güzel sanatlar, e, güzel
sanatların da amacı nedir? Onlar da aynı
şekilde edebiyat gibi aynı kaynaktan
beslenir. Yani insanın duygu, düşünce ve
hayallerinden beslenir. İnsanda bir
coşku uyandırmak, hayal gücünü harekete
geçirmek ve güzeli yansıtmak şeklinde
bir amaca sahiptir. Güzel sanatlar da
güzel sanatlardan kastım mesela resim,
heykel, mimari, müzik değil mi? Sinema,
dans, tiyatro. Bunları kastediyorum.
Şimdi düşünsenize bir müzik insanın
kalbine dokunur. Resim renklerle
birlikte duygularımızı dile getirir.
Heykelde taş can bulur. Değil mi? Yani
bir taşı düşünün. Oradan öyle bir sanat
ürünü ortaya koyar ki heykel tıraş o taş
adeta bir can bulur, hayat bulur.
Mimaride bir yapı tüm ihtişamıyla bir
ruhu etkiler. İşte bu tüm sanatların
ortak noktasıdır. Yine aynı şekilde tüm
diğer sanatlar gibi edebiyatta insana
güzellik ve estetik bir has sunmaya
çalışır. Yani bir resim sanatı gibi, bir
mimari gibi, bir heykel gibi, bir müzik,
resim gibi edebiyatın amacı insanın o
estetik ruhuna dokunabilmek. Mesela
güzel bir resim gördüğünüz,
seyrediyorsunuz. Heykel gördüğünüz,
seyrediyorsunuz. Mimari hayranlıkla
gezersiniz. Edebiyat ürünü de bir şiir,
roman olabilir. Hayranlıklı okursunuz ve
okudukça bu işten zevk alırsınız.
Dolayısıyla aslında edebiyat ve güzel
sanatın böyle ortak bir yönü vardır
diyebiliriz.
Şimdi güzel sanatın asıl amacı insana
estetik zevk vermektir. Yani onlara
sadece bilgi ya da fayda kazandırmak
amacıyla güzel sanatlar oluşmamıştır.
Ortaya çıkmamıştır. Amaç duygu
coşkunluğunu estetik hazı verebilmektir.
Bu da sanatı diğer türlerden ayırır.
Mesela zanaat kavramı ön plana
çıkacaktır. Bu derst zanaat diye şuraya
yazalım. Şimdi zanaatla sanat arasında
bayağı bir fark vardır. Zanaatın amacı
nedir? insanlara bir fayda sağlamaktır.
Mesela bir ressam, resim çizerken bu
insanlığın şu soruna cevap versin, şu
ihtiyacını gidersin ya da bu şiir
insanın şu ihtiyacını gidersin diye
yazılmaz ki. Ama zanaat ürünü öyle
değildir. Zanaat ürünü mesela bir
sandalye ya da düşünsenize bir masa, çok
güzel bir masa, bir jam bardak, bir
kahte vesaire ya güzel bir şekilde usta
bunu ortaya koyar ama amacı nedir?
insanın bir ihtiyacına cevap vermektir.
İşte su içme, ne bileyim yemek yerken bu
masaya kullanması, oturması vesaire.
Tabii onu süsler püsler ama asıl amaç
onun yani insanın bir ihtiyacına cevap
verebilmektir. Dolayısıyla sanatla
zanaat arasında ya da diğer dallar
arasında böyle bir fark vardır.
Kesinlikle bir fayda sağlamak gibi amacı
yoktur sanatın. E doğal olarak
edebiyatın da böyle bir amacı
olmayacaktır. Peki sanatın amacı nedir?
Hemen altını çizmek istiyorum. Şöyle
ekranda da gözüküyordur. Tamam. Sanatın
temel amacı güzeli bulmak, güzeli
yansıtmak, güzeli insana ulaştırmaktır.
Böyle bir amacı vardır sanatın. Temel
amacı budur. Yani resmin de, edebiyatın
da, bununla birlikte mimarinin de,
heykelin de, sinemanın, dansın, ballenin
burada gördüğünüz tüm sanatların temel
amacı güzeli bulmak, güzeli yansıtmak,
güzeli insana ulaştırmak gibi bir amacı
vardır. Şimdi güzel sanatlar. Birçok
sanattan bahsettik değil mi? Ama bu
sanatı biz kendi içerisinde
kullandıkları malzemeye göre bir ya da
ifade etme tarzlarına göre bir
gruplandırma yapıyoruz. Genel anlamda
güzel sanatlar üç ana başlıkla
sınıflandırılır. İşitsel yani fonatik
sanatlar, görsel yani plastik sanatlar,
dramatik yani ritmik sanatlar olacak.
Ritmik sanatlar olacak. Bu şekilde bir
sınıflandırma yapabiliriz. Şimdi
kullanılan malzeme ya mesela eğer sese
edebiyat ve müzik devreye girer değil
mi? Sese dayalı olan iki sanat vardır.
Müzik ve edebiyat. Görsel yani göze
hitap eden şekil vermek plastik yönü de
bunu ifade eder. Orada da resim, heykel
ve mimari sonuç itibariyle sen mesela
bir taşı düşün buna şekil veriyorsun.
Kağıdı düşün boyalarla buraya bir şekil
veriyorsun. Dolayısıyla bunlar plastik
yani görsel sanatlardır. Bir de dramatik
yani ritmik harekete dayalı olan
sanatlar vardır. Tiyatro böyledir,
sinema böyledir, dans böyledir, bale
böyledir, opera böyledir. Ya opera hocam
müzik değil midir diye soracak olursanız
hemen orada da bir açıklama yapalım.
Opera tiyatronun bir alt dalıdır. Yani
aslında operada sadece şarkı söylemek,
müzik söylemek gibi bir amaç yoktur. O
müzik üzerinden, o şarkı üzerinden
aslında bir olay anlatılır. Dolayısıyla
bir tiyatro çeşidi olarak geçer. Bu
nedenle yeri dramatik yani ritmik
sanatlar kategorisindedir. Bunu da
unutma. Şimdi bu tabloyu bilmekte fayda
var. Çünkü sınavda karşımıza çıkacak.
Ben inanıyorum ki buradan bir soru
gelecektir. Güzel sanatlarla ilgili soru
gelecektir. Bu tablonun da gelme
ihtimali çok yüksek. Size sorulur. İşte
boşluklar verilir sorularda. Bu
boşlukları doldurmanız istenir vesaire.
Dolayısıyla bu tabloyu bilmekte büyük
bir fayda var. Şimdi hani söz konusu
edebiyat ya. Şimdi edebiyatla güzel
sanatın ilişkisine bakıyoruz. Hatta
başlığımız neydi? Bak bir kez daha
hatırlatalım. Edebiyatın güzel
sanatlarla ilişkisi ya da kitapta
edebiyatın güzel sanatlar içindeki yeri
şeklinde de geçebilir. O yüzden şöyle
edebiyatla sanatın bağlantılarına
bakalım. Ne gibi ortak yönleri var? Ne
gibi farklı özellikleri var? Buradan da
soru gelebilir. Dikkatlice
dinliyorsunuz. Şimdi ortak yönlerinden
bir tanesi estetik bir amaç taşıması.
Yani amacı nedir edebiyatın? diğer
sanatlar gibi, müzik gibi, resim gibi,
tiyatro gibi insanda güzellik duygusu
oluşturabilmektir. Yine duygulara
seslenebilmektir ve kendi içerisinde
içsel bir uyum ve bütünlük barındırır.
Yani nasıl ki bir müzik notaların uyumlu
olmasına dayanıyorsa, resim sanatına
renklerin uyumlu olmasına dayanıyorsa
burada da sözcüklerin ne olmasına
dayanır? Edebiyat sanatında uyumlu
olmasına dayanır. Aynen bir müzik notası
gibi. Yani notalar yan yana uyumlu bir
şekilde dizilirse güzel bir müzik ortaya
çıkar. Rastgele dizilirse karmakarışık
bir ses ortaya çıkar. Bu da insanların
hoşuna gitmeyecektir. Aynı şey edebiyat
için de geçerli. Sözcüklerin böyle
uyumlu, ahenkli bir şekilde sıralanması,
yan yana getirilmesi gerekiyor. Böyle
olmazsa e edebiyat sanatından
bahsedemeyiz. Peki şimdi gelelim
farkına. En büyük farkı nedir? Bu da
çıkabilir. Edebiyatın diğer güzel sanat
dallarından ayrılan yönü nedir diye
sorulursa hemen aklınıza malzeme
gelecek. Yani malzeme farklıdır. Şimdi
resmin malzemesi nedir? Renklerdir,
boyadır, şövalyedir, palettir, değil mi?
Heykelin malzemesi taştır, mermerdir.
İşte onu eee şekil verebilmek için
çeşitli aletler kullanılır vesaire.
Şimdi her sanatın farklı malzemesi
vardır. Edebiyatın malzemesi
sözcüklerdir. Yani edebiyatın malzemesi
dildir. Bu dil yönüyle diğer güzel sanat
dallarından ayrılır. Edebiyat.
Dolayısıyla böyle bir farkı vardır aynı
zamanda. Şimdi bu dil yani sözcükler
bağlama göre yani ortama göre
kullanıldığı yere göre farklı anlamlar
kazanabilir. Dolayısıyla bu da edebiyatı
daha da karmaşık hale getirir. Daha da
güzel hale getirir aslında. Yoksa her
kelime gerçek anlamıyla, sözlük
anlamıyla kullanılırsa o zaman biz orada
bir güzellikten bahsedemeyiz. Farklı
anlamlar yüklendiği için, farklı
anlamlar çağrıştırdığı için, herkese
farklı şeyler kattığı için edebiyat aynı
zamanda zengin bir sanattır diyebiliriz.
Bence bu da önemli karşımıza çıkabilir.
Şöyle bir soru. Aman dikkat. Edebiyatı
diğer güzel sanat dallarından ayıran
fark nedir? Hemen yazacaksın.
Malzemesidir. Yani dilidir. Evet. Şimdi
sanattan bahsettik. Hadi gelin bir
etkinliğimizi yapalım. Ne diyor?
Aşağıdaki cümleleri dikkatli okuyunuz.
Her bir cümlede hangi sanatalığın
anlatıldığına karar veriniz ve yan
kutuca yazınız. Taşın içinde gizli duran
bedeni ellerimle günyüzüne çıkardım. Her
vuruşumda cansız mermerden yavaş yavaş
bir hayat fışkırıyordu. Burada değil mi?
Mermerin ya da bir taşın şekil
almasından, hayat bulmasından, can
bulmasından bahsediliyor. Tabii ki
heykel sanatı karşımıza geliyor.
Sözcükler bir melodinin notaları gibi
kalbime dokundu. Her dize içimde bir
şarkı gibi yükseldi. Duygularımı
ezgilerle kanatlandırdı. Şimdi burada
sözcükler bir melodinin notaları gibi
kalbime dokundu diyor ya. O zaman
sözcükler ön planda. Melodi var ama bu
bir tuzak. Edebiyat sanatından
bahsediyoruz. Devam edelim. Bir sahnede
yüzlerce insan aynı anda nefesini tuttu.
Perde açıldığında roller yalnızca
oyuncuların değil izleyenlerin de
kalbini işlemişti. Şimdi sahne diyor,
izleyiciler diyor, perde diyor. O zaman
tiyatro sanatı ön plana çıkacaktır.
Renkler fırçamın ucunda birbirine
karıştı. Güneşin batışını tuvalet
açıdığımda sanki ellerimde yeniden can
buldu bu manzara. diyor. Dolayısıyla
resim sanatından bahsediyor değil mi?
Fırça, renkler vesaire varsa, tuvalsa
resim sanatı hemen aklımıza gelecek.
Yüksek kubbelerin altında yankılanan
adımlar taş ve mermerin ihtişamıyla
birleşti. İnsan kendini göğe
yükseliyormuş gibi hissetti. Yüksek
kubelerin altında yani bir cami gezmiş
gibi hissediyorum. Altta taş, mermerler,
kubbeler aynı zamanda orada manevi
anlamda göğe yükseliyormuş gibi
hissedersin. Dolayısıyla bu bir mimari
sanatını çağrıştırıyor. Dolayısıyla
mimari sanatı buraya gelecek. Cevapları
da buradan kontrol edebilirsiniz. Şimdi
bir başka etkinimiz var. diyor ki,
"Aşağıda farklı sanat dalları ile ilgili
kısa tanımlar verilmiştir. Bu tanımların
hangisinin edebiyata ait olduğunu
belirleyiniz di" diyor. Renk ve
çizgilerle duygu ve düşünceleri ifade
eder. Renk ve çizgi varsa e tabii ki bu
resim sanatı olacaktır. Söz ve yazıyla
duygu, düşünce, hayalleri estetik
biçimde yansıtır. Edebiyat sanatından
bahsediyoruz, değil mi? Çünkü edebiyatın
görevi söz ve yazıyı kullanması ve söz
ve yazıyla duygu ve düşüncelerin,
hayallerin ifade edilmesidir. Ses ve
ezgi yoluyla coşku uyandırır. Şimdi ses
ve ezgi, ses var, ezgi var. E bu müzik
sanatını çağrıştırıyor. Dolayısıyla
müzik olacak. Hareket ve sözle izleyici
olayları sahnede sunar. Tiyatro
sanatından bahsediyoruz. Taş ya da metal
gibi maddeleri şekillendirerek ifade
oluşturur. Burada da heykel sanatından
bahsetmek mümkündür. Şekil vermek. O
şekil üzerinden de çeşitli anlamları
ifade etmek heykel sanatının bir
görevidir. Dolaysa heykel sanatı gelmeli
buraya diyoruz ve böylelikle edebiyatın
güzel sanatlarla ilişkisini bitirmiş
olduk. Önemli ders kitabımızda da önemli
bir yeri var. Sınavda da buradan mutlaka
bir soru gelecektir. Şaşırmayın. Gelirse
de bu dediğimde aklınıza kalsın. Öyleyse
ben konumu bitirdim. Dersimi bitirdim.
Artık veda etme zamanı. Bir sonraki
derste tekrar görüşeceğiz ama o zamana
kadar kendine çok iyi bakıyorsun. Ama
lütfen ayrılmadan önce Deniz Hocan'ı 1
milyona doğru giderken desteklemeyi
unutma. Yani bu videoyu beğenir kanalıma
abone olursan aynı zamanda 9. sınıf
WhatsApp kanalımız var. Videonun
açıklamalar kısmında mutlaka oraya da
gel bence. Oraya da gelirsen kendine
büyük bir iyilik yapmış olursun. Bir yıl
boyunca kitapta etkinlik yapacaksın. O
etkinlikleri nasıl yapacağın? Oradaki
konular ne? Bunu öğrenmek için de 9.
sınıf ders kitabımızı
inceleyebilirsiniz. Onun da linki yine
videonun açıklamalar kısmında. Biz bir
sene boyunca onu kullanacağız. Aynı
zamanda yazılı soruları da içinde. Onu
da hatırlatmış olayım. E öyleyse bir
sonraki derste görüşürüz. Hoşça kal.